[Music]
wait can we can we start
with the with the uh mark zuckerberg
edit
oh sure yeah like we got to watch this
okay
it's now recognized for fun wait do you
want this full screen yeah yeah sure
so he was a zuckerberg like testified to
congress i guess for
not congress i don't know whatever it's
like an anti-trust
lawsuit or something like that right
yeah yeah or anti-competition because if
it's like
uh acquisition of instagram i don't know
but someone made this edit and it's so
[ __ ] funny yeah who who made this
[ __ ]
uh elliott etc ali at etc
thanks bro this is on twitter thank you
mr cook
mr zuckerberg is now recognized for five
minutes
hey how's it going we are live from my
backyard
where i am smoking a brisket and some
ribs
so you know the thing about about
smoking meat
is that it takes a long time and you
just end up sitting around for a while
so i figured that it would be
pretty fun to smoke a bunch of stuff
like a brisket
it's actually pretty easy you open up
the lid and you put
some charcoal at the bottom and then you
put some
wood chips on top if you want to give it
a smoky flavor and uh
and and you just kind of go through how
perfect you guys making for dinner
brisket ribs i hope delicious a sweet
baby raised barbecue sauce that is going
on the ribs
you know the thing that really makes it
good and i think half of half of the joy
is that things taste better when you
make them yourself dude that is gays
they taste doubly better half of the joy
half of the joy he looks like he's in a
gusher's commercial like
permanently like his [ __ ] eyeballs
are
so scary man what is it
i know people rip on him all the time
but he really if anyone was like a
secret lizard
it's him yeah you know like i was
listening i don't know if you heard post
on
rogan uh but they talked about like
aliens for like an hour
uh oh when a pose won a rogue and when
yeah yeah yesterday
oh i didn't know that yeah you weren't
listening to it in the cart
no it wasn't yeah i wasn't blasting a
podcast in the car unfortunately
um they're talking about like you know
aliens that are
that are like living as humans right now
right if anyone is that it's it's him
for sure what is with billionaires
tech billionaires and having big ass
eyes like his yeah
his eyes and jeff bezos eye yeah
i wonder who else got a big eye anyway
yeah i don't i just want to know like
was he always like this
definitely even i mean i guess you kind
of
picture him being like this and then
making the original facebook where he's
like it's a website where
like listen to this [ __ ] words didn't
it start with you could rank women
dude you you just rated them like yeah i
was the first that was
the most inspirated women although
better
and then he ranks them based on hottest
yeah like the most amount of ratings
so that that i think that i think
like i can't even do his [ __ ] [ __ ] i
know
half the joy half the joy is the
barbecue sauce something like sweet baby
rays
half the joy of hot or not is i figured
that it would be it's pretty fun to
smoke his voice is like in the back of
his throat it's like
ha ha it's kind of like crunchy buddy
i can't do it nope
i can't even do it yeah what the [ __ ]
it's gone pigs are in zuckerberg in
[ __ ] college uh
it's it's it's a website why are you
[ __ ] he just he just is onesie buddy
were you rape women by the way
his roommate dude like the very first
person he told that [ __ ] to his roommate
must have been looking at him like
oh man that's kind of [ __ ] up
he's like no you don't get it all these
women that have rejected me
i now have the upper hand i just
i picture it more like he's just
doesn't know how to react like he
doesn't even really process that it's
[ __ ] up yet it's just weird you know
what i mean like
yeah yeah it's like mark just comes into
their communal whatever and he's like
you can rate women from the school
okay they're like but why would we want
to do that
to see who is the hottest
oh yeah i mean we all have like
that's you know sort of we all have
different opinions on on that
no wouldn't be cool if it was
crowdsourced and we all knew
this way we can collect the data and
figure out who's the hottest in the
school
based on an average that i've calculated
and then i can blackmail her into
marrying me
second day this mom calls honey how's
your first day how's your roommate
um yeah i don't know man i don't know if
it's gonna work out
harvard's weird yeah i don't really i
kind of just want to go to community
college with my friends
this is this school is [ __ ] [ __ ] up
man
i want to be here
oh my god
[Laughter]
wouldn't that be cool if we all knew
i'm just walking around at a party with
a [ __ ] macbook
trying to explain his stupid website
yeah
and no one will listen
see no sadie sadie right now you're
third you see
who the [ __ ] is this guy i have no
[ __ ] clue who he is he keeps talking
to me
he just moved down to fourth
[Laughter]
he's just chasing girls around yeah
you're on the list
you're on the list lisa you're top ten
can you believe it everyone
okay yeah he's trying his he's trying
his he's drawing genuinely his hardest
to not be creepy
but it's just the creepiest thing ever
congratulations jane you're number five
i always thought that you were
definitely top five hottest
it's gotta be it's not me though it's
crowdsourced it's everyone else it's not
i didn't ranked it i didn't you
it's not me you know you know the
winklevosses only sued him
because they were so mad this dude like
mark
got one over on them yeah like that's
just like
these two [ __ ] chad investors that
are like i can't believe this fool
[ __ ]
got us out this [ __ ]
like picturing the original winklevosses
and mark
like it everyone has i feel like that
image like we all laugh about mark but
when we saw
you know social network or whatever of
course you
you think of him as like jesse whatever
the [ __ ] his name is
army hammer no no who's the actor who
played mark zuckerberg
oh yeah yeah uh jesse withers
witherspoon whether it's real oh yeah um
oh sylvester stallone when sylvester
stallone i think it was
was playing yeah when reese witherspoon
was playing mark zuckerberg
[Laughter]
dude when the rock was playing mark
zuckerberg
when he walked in that room and he was
like all right [ __ ]
that sort of stone cold
sorry i made a website and um
i want to find out if the girls are hot
or not
and i want to know if you're in
you're in
then yeah army hammer in the corner like
well
army hammer is the weirdest voice man
yeah he does
he definitely does
good actor though yeah good actor
well jesse um i want to know what's in
it for us for the facebook
yeah that's good did you watch i've made
so many call me by your name jokes that
dude in that movie
i could not take it seriously i haven't
seen it yet i could not take his [ __ ]
seriously man
why this [ __ ] voice
like already so like i guess the premise
of the book was that like they were a
bit closer in age but when i saw like
him next to timothy chalamet i'm like
isn't isn't this kind of like isn't he
like 40. like
yeah it kind of looks decades older than
me yeah
yeah like even from the preview i was
like this is
weird this looks [ __ ] illegal like
straight
up yeah but yeah i guess in the book it
wasn't supposed to be that way i think
that was like a common chris
like criticism of the film like yeah
okay the film looked good but
you couldn't have maybe chose somebody
like looks a little bit younger
yeah i just just his voice makes me
laugh i don't know why man
hello timothy i would like to kiss you
on the lips
i'm very attracted to you yeah yeah
i want to chase you through the house
and then read you a book it's just like
it's like i don't know
anyway anyway yes when the rock played
mark zuckerberg i don't know i feel like
the social network made mark
seem like this [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
yeah like ultra smart yeah [ __ ]
knows that he's gonna be successful like
he's gonna have a dick
no soon it's super dick yeah yeah like
he's like oh man
you're like man mark is a [ __ ] savage
five years later we get i would the joy
of smoking meat
the joy of smoking these meats
brisket maybe some chicken put some
sweet baby rays on there
and i actually you can rank the meats
you can
i have uh
i've created a ranking site meetrank.com
head on over to meat rank oh boy the
content needs moderation
that's so [ __ ] stupid i'm gonna make
that i'm gonna
i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna do it today
you